je vais vous le dire d'entrée
mon message est très surprenant
l'intelligence artificielle est une
nouvelle opportunité pour l'égalité mon
message est très surprenant parce que
vous avez souvent entendu à la radio ou
à la télé des exemples d'applications
qui guidés par l'intelligence
artificielle accentuer les inégalités
on prend par exemple il existe une étude
de microsoft et du hem haïti en 2018 qui
ont démontré que l'intelligence
artificielle pour la classification
d'image se tromper 100 fois plus sur les
femmes que sur les hommes de plus 82%
des conférenciers en intelligence
artificielle sont des hommes
80 % des professeurs en intelligence
artificielle sont des hommes un rapport
du forum économique mondial a démontré
qu'à partir au jour d'aujourd'hui il
nous faudrait 200 deux ans pour combler
l'écart entre les hommes et les femmes
à moins d'une accélération du processus
et justement cette accélération sera
déjà ça
je m'appelle
minichetti je travaille chez ibm dans le
big data et l'intelligence artificielle
et dans ce cadre là j'ai l'honneur et le
plaisir de participer à des initiatives
dans les collèges les lycées les
universités pour la promotion des femmes
dans les sciences et les métiers de
l'ingénieur à chacune de mes
interventions je pose aux jeunes garçons
un jeune fille ces techniques à un père
et fille sont dans une voiture ils ont
un accident le père meurt de suite
brutalement on amène d'urgence le fils à
l'hôpital
on fait venir d'urgence le chirurgien à
et lorsque le chirurgien arrive devant
un patient il dit je ne peux pas
l'opérer ses montées
or comment c'est possible qu'ils aient
toujours des réponses très souvent
farfelues et quoi qu'il en soit cet
animé le parfait exemple des billets
sexistes inconscient que nous avons
l'exemple du bief sexistes qu'on
retrouve dans des milliards et des
milliards de lignes de code informatique
je vais vous prendre un exemple
d'application
vous utilisez tous les jours le chat
lorsque je veux envoyer une limite qui
compte d'une personne qui fait son
footing
le pape est raccourci clavier revenus il
apparaît c'est systématiquement l'image
d'un homme dans le passé les
programmeurs se sont aperçus de leur
erreur ils ont voulu la corriger leur
première solution était de créer deux
raccourcis bien xd running horse korman
pour les hommes et running
1-1 score vous mène pour les femmes mais
ça ne marche pas c'est un poème très
connu dans l'informatique qu'on appelle
la compatibilité ascendante
il faut que la nouvelle version du
logiciel corrigés sont compatibles avec
l'ancienne version
et dans ce cas cela ne marchait plus il
y avait un problème d'expérience
d'utilisateurs
cela ne se vendait pas plan de marche
est ils ont une deuxième idée de se dire
on va rajouter un raccourci
supplémentaires browning plus le symbole
venus mais là aussi j'ai un problème
d'expérience utilisateur
personne ne sait où est le symbole venus
sur son clavier et donc au final on voit
bien l'extrême difficulté qu'il ya de
modifier des billets en femme dans du
code informatique dit classique mais
j'en arrive donc à mon premier point de
mon message
l'intelligence artificielle change par
adeline de programmation et facilite
donc d'égalité enfin avec la
sic je dois écrire de manière explicite
dans mon code toutes les règles du
métier toute la logique de mon métier
ainsi si je veux faire reconnaître et
comprendre ce que c'est un vélo à une
codes classiques
je dois codé en dur qu'un vélo possède
deux pédales deux roues un guide avec
l'indigence
ciel je change tout cela la machine va
apprendre d'elle même de manière
implicite à travers des bases
entraînement à travers des milliers des
millions de données ainsi un fournissant
des millions et des millions d'image de
vélo à mon intelligence artificielle
la machine va découvrir d'elle-même
qu'un verrou possède deux roues de
pédales un guidon et donc non seulement
l'intelligence artificielle permet de
détecter et corriger les biais beaucoup
plus facilement qu'avec la programmation
classique mais le facilite aussi par
rapport aux humains je vous prends un
autre exemple ce qu'on appelle le
processus de recrutement de candidats ou
documents rh
si je veux dans la vraie vie pouvait et
démontrer une discrimination
il nous faudra trouver deux candidats un
homme une femme qui ont exactement le
même âge qui ont exactement la même
couleur de peau qui ont même profil la
même expérience la même compétence pour
prouver la discrimination
cela va être très lourd et très contexte
ça me prend du temps avec l'intelligence
artificielle il me suffira de fournir 2
cv qui diffère uniquement sur le sexe et
au delà de la détection
lorsqu'il faudra que je corrige la
discrimination avec l'intelligence
artificielle il me suffira de mettre des
nouvelles données sur les femmes de
mettre plus de cv de femmes dans
l'entraînement et devrait entraîner une
intelligence artificielle
s'il veut
j'ai la mentalité des recruteurs rh ça
va être beaucoup plus compliqué avec des
siècles et des siècles de tradition de
culture et d'éducation
l'intelligence machine est beaucoup plus
flexible que l'intelligence humaine
d'ailleurs des humains ont très peur de
l' indignation artificielle et j'en
arrive au deuxième point de mon message
l'intelligence artificielle est devenu à
aujourd'hui le sujet de société et les
femmes représentent la moitié de la
société
l'intelligence artificielle est une
solution disruptive qui va se déployer
dans tous les domaines de l'industrie
dans tous les domaines de notre vie
quotidienne
les acteurs de l'intelligence
artificielle ont bien compris que s'ils
voulaient que l'intelligence
artificielle soit adopté il faudra
qu'elle inspire confiance aux
consommateurs et aux citoyens que nous
sommes
et donc
actuellement les acteurs de
l'intelligence artificielle travaille
sur plusieurs points il travaille sur
l'esprit kabylité l'algorithme
d'intelligence artificielle se doit
d'être explicable mon algorithmes de
recrutement rh va détailler sa prise de
décision en expliquant sur quelles
données ils se basent si je m'aperçois
que 80% du poids de la décision est
basée sur le sexe je détecte et corrige
le bien il se doit d'être aussi
équitable parmi la centaine des milliers
d'attributs que je mets un critère
d'entraînement de l'algorithme je vais
jouer sur un seul le sexe je vais
collectés alors pourcentage de femmes
recrutées gelé collectés alors le
pourcentage d'hommes recrutés et je vais
faire le ratio si ce ratio dépasse 2 3
ou 4 je déclenche et corrige le bien et
donc
final les informaticiens ne travaille
plus tout seul comme il le faisait dans
la programmation classique
il travaille de plus en plus avec des
non informaticiens il travaille de plus
en plus avec des 10 des directrices de
ressources humaines avec des
psychologues
avec des agents bancaires avec des
linguistes et donc les femmes sont de
plus en plus impliqué dans le design le
développement et l'implémentation de
l'intelligence artificielle
là où elles représentaient seulement 10%
la programmation classique en 1980 et
aujourd'hui à + 15 % en 2020 et donc
pour conclure lorsque je
mais je suis forcément biaisé
essentiellement des billets inconscient
que l'informatique ultra masculine issus
du mythe du guide ultra masculin du
mythe de l'ordinateur personnel a
diffusé un fusée est codé d'al-ahmar
dans des milliards de lignes de code et
l'intelligence artificielle change ce
paradis au lieu de coder en dur de
manière explicite les règles dans mon
programme
la machine va les apprendre d'elle même
et pour corriger les biais me suffira de
la aurait entraîné avec des nouvelles
données c'est beaucoup plus facile et
flexible que de vouloir changer les
mentalités des humains figées dans des
siècles de clichés et pour finir dernier
point l'intelligence artificielle est
une nouvelle page vierge en cours
d'écriture et donc sous le poids des
lois sous le poids de l'adoption du
marché sous le contrôle de l'humain qui
en a peur elle se doit d'être forcément
transparente explicable équitable et
donc au final égalitaire c'est pourquoi
foncièrement l'intelligence artificielle
va être un accélérateur de la réduction
des inégalités hommes-femmes et si c'est
pas demain ça sera après demain je
finirai par une citation de isaac asimov
célèbre écrivain américain biochimiste
d'origine russe qui disait dans toute
bonne cause il n'y a pas d'échec il n'y
a que des succès différé merci de votre
attention